hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my agents of shield episode 18 video
just careful for spoilers if you haven't
seen it yet all kinds of sex making
happening between Inhumans between
regular shield agents that was the whole
meaning of the episode the singularity
crossing the threshold having sex for
the first time anybody who lost their
virginity in high school will totally
understand the conversation that Fitz
and Simmons is happening if your version
of the conversation included that much
science speak you're probably rich
geniuses at this point the reason that
was probably the funniest part of the
episode there was a lot of comedy in the
episode especially with Hellfires
character but the reason why I think
Fitz and Simmons worked so well
especially in that moment is because
it's so real
you spend all this time worrying about
crossing the threshold together and then
you come to the same conclusion that
they came to you just have to do it give
me all your eyeball operation
penetration jokes just like bamp just
got to get it over with
so lots of Easter eggs lots of Captain
America Civil War crossover so I'll
explain all that stuff they had Captain
America's energy shield freaking awesome
so here we go top 5 WTF and easter eggs
number 5 cut the head off of Hydra so
this is the big Captain America Civil
War crossover caps energy shield isn't
really a crossover but you can kind of
see how like the minute Coulson busted
that out he got a call from Talbot that
was doing the Civil War stuff just
cutting all the heads off of Hydra
thanks to Malik's information so this
doesn't mean that hydras gone for good
it just means that they've been laid low
they are essentially non-existent at
this point when you go to see Captain
America Civil War you'll see how some
new villains will be on the rise Baron
Zemo is a version of that now he's not
called Baron Zemo and Captain America's
Civil War but we can talk more about
that after the movie comes out there's
just a lot of other big villain things
going on in the world besides Hydra this
is just meant to show you that like okay
Hydra essentially gone but now the
Inhumans are kind of the villains
although you know technically that's not
true because it's really just the
Inhumans that hive has turned that had
become the villains but if you guys
didn't know Captain America's energy
shield debuted in volume 3 issue 1 so it
was like you know right off the bat BAM
energy shield check out this awesome new
toy the writer of that issue was Mark
Waid which maybe is a surprise maybe not
a surprise
Mark Waid had just been attached to so
many big comic book thing
recently but operationally Captain
America's version of the shield works
just like the way you see Coulson use it
it just projects from a base that he
keeps in one of his gauntlets but other
characters have also used the same
technology for energy claws
taskmaster has used a version of it even
Spiderman used it to simulate web
shooters so the TV show just having a
little bit of fun with it because so
much Captain America stuff is happening
and Coulson even had his bloody Captain
America cards - that was more of a hat
tip to the rally moment now is the
moment when you need to nut up and take
down hive speaking of which number four
WTF Fitz and Simmons finally nut up and
closed the deal so to speak like I said
they had a lot of fun with sex language
crossing the threshold the singularity
penetration with this eyeball here they
were totally on fire in this episode
number three WTF to Hellfire becomes an
inhuman well technically his name wasn't
Hellfire before but this is who he is is
a big character from the comics he's
also part of the secret warriors at a
certain point so even though the TV show
version of the character is a little
over the top
they are definitely pulling stuff right
out of the comics and because the status
of the Inhumans movie is now pending
like it's been taken off of Marvel's
film schedule they might be able to do
some more royal family things maybe a
tool and maybe some of the bigger
characters you know remains remains to
be seen but number two WTF Coulson makes
Lincoln where the murder vest I totally
loved how sinister this was just like
ooh this is dark no it's not a suicide
vest it's a murder vests Lincoln's quick
reboot made him a little bit more fun
there were some good Lincoln moments in
the episode really dark a little bit of
funny but that's where shield is right
now the tone of the show has gone really
dark but they still find ways to jam in
a lot of great jokes number one WTF
though hive buys a town with Malik's
funds remember he said let's spend some
of this money that he's worked so hard
to earn so he bought that town they're
gonna try and recreate the original Kree
experiment that created the first
Inhumans so this is a really big deal
and he's stolen the device like the orb
in the base device they can destroy him
it'll come back closer to the finale and
that's probably gonna be how they'll
deal with hive but the scientists you
probably recognize from the mummy films
may be from somewhere else his name is
John Hannah that's the name of the actor
but he's been in a ton of stuff so I'm
totally happy that they were able to use
them on the TV show but let me know in
the comments what was your favorite
moment from this what
you think about the Captain America
Civil War crossover stuff it's so
awesome that they were able to destroy
shield in the Captain America movies and
then the TV show was able to destroy
Hydra so it's like alright we'll do you
one better
boom bye Hydra but that's not really the
end of civil war stuff they'll continue
to be civil war stuff happening in next
week's episode all the way through the
worldwide premiere Civil War has been
dropping around the world different
times so some of you might be seeing the
movie now please don't post spoilers in
the comments or at least use a spoiler
tag but I will be posting a bunch of
Civil War videos next week I'll do a
non-spoilery review that won't post til
like next Thursday then I'll do an
Easter Egg video I'll do all kinds of
stuff there's so much stuff in that
movie we have to talk about it's
probably gonna go down as the best
Avengers movie if not the best Marvel
movie so far everybody has their
favorite Marvel film so that's up for a
debate like Winter Soldier is one of the
best films so far this film is probably
gonna be even better than Winter Soldier
while you guys wait for me to post my
next video you can click here for my
spider-man Civil War video from last
night and you can click here to watch
the Batman Killing Joke trailer thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight
you